gestern hatte die spd übrigens eine top
gelegenheit die groko platzen zu lassen
sie hätten nur im bundestag zusammen mit
linken grünen und fdp den § 209 10 a
kippen müssen im volksmund das
werbeverbot für abtreibung frauen sind
ja insgesamt das wissen sie so was wie
die gebärmutter aller probleme und
schwangerschafts abbrüche sind ein
ethisch hoch komplexes thema fakt ist
aber auch frauen in so einer
notsituation müssen sich informieren
können
union und fdp waren aber vor werbung für
werbung und es wird ja langsam auch echt
zu viel mit dieser abtreibungs werbung
überall oder in stadien auf flugzeug
bannern auf den helm von formel 1
fahrern
deswegen fragt ja die afd ist werbung an
abbrüchen für abbrüche etwas solchen
anstößig oder erster mann drei abbrüche
zum preis von zweien anbietet tja und
wenn man um frauen zu diffamieren
werbung erfindet die es überhaupt nicht
gibt ist man dann als politiker
ungeeignet oder einfach charakterlich
das hinterletzte ein seltsames
frauenbild haben die verteidiger des
paragrafen 219 adi gehen offenbar
grundsätzlich von der sorglosen dummen
frauen aus die wenn man mal drei
sekunden nicht aufpasst sofort schwanger
sind
und dann lesen sie in der brigitte eine
werbung für eine abtreibungsklinik und
wollen das natürlich sofort haben frauen
halt und um mal ganz kurz auf die
realität zu kommen es gibt kaum noch
ärzte die in deutschland überhaupt
abbrüche vornehmen nicht zuletzt weil
die so genannten lebensschützer immer
radikaler werden die gehören die haben
sogar die veranstalten sogar einen
online pranger für die paar mediziner an
die sich frauen heute noch wenden können
letzte woche hat ein gericht in gießen
bestätigt dass dr christina himmel
tatsächlich 6000 euro strafe zahlen muss
und zwar nur weil sie auf ihrer homepage
patientinnen ganz sachlich informiert
dass sie abbrüche vornimmt
ein urteil das selbst dem richter
peinlich war er sagte nach der
verkündung sie solle das urteil wie
einen ehrentitel tragen im kampf um ein
besseres gesetz immerhin ein ehrentitel
hat karl-theodor zu guttenberg nicht
und achten sie mal darauf bei den
lebensschützern marschieren vor allem
mittelalte bis alte männer denen die
selbstbestimmung der frau an sich ein
dorn im auge ist übrigens dieselben
typen die regelmäßig gegen sexual bundes
in der schule agitieren echt verblüffend
wie gnadenlos gerade opfers mit zu viel
tagesfreizeit über frauen urteilen dann
beginnt papst franziskus sich von seinem
redetext zu lösen und frei zu reden
dabei kommt er direkt zum thema
abtreibung weil die vorher eines
menschen zu beseitigen ist wie die
inanspruchnahme eines auftragsmörders um
ein problem zu lösen das passiert wenn
msc franziskus freestyle freunde
auftragsmord soweit ist wirklich noch
kein papst gegangen noch keiner
es ist doch immer der version liberaler
reformer weiß ich nicht mehr viel von
übrig geblieben außer dass er ganz
bescheiden sein fiat 500 fährt das zeug
wirklich von gott vertraut muss man
sagen aber ansonsten ja wo sind denn die
großen reformen
allerdings muss ich sagen bin ich beim
thema kirche vorsichtig geworden sie
wissen ja ich habe hier in dieser
sendung im april aus versehen einen
osterhasen gekreuzigt und das ging bis
in den fernsehrat deswegen dass ich mich
in solchen fällen ab jetzt theologisch
beraten von unserem zdf haus kaplan
johannes maria stocker aus halo 500
werke ich gehe gerade schon mal ihre
witzige durch also wunderbar so
großartig können wir alle nicht machen
aber ich hatte sie unterbrochen sie
sprachen gerade von unserem reform papst
ja reform papst wie gesagt welche
reformen erst der spruch mit dem
auftragsmord und dann hat der vatikan in
rom auch noch ansgar wucherpfennig den
rektor einer katholischen hochschule in
frankfurt quasi gefeiert und zwar nur
weil er homosexuelle paare segnet nicht
mal verheiratet segnet ja wenn er sie
verheiratet dann müssen ihn verbrennen
katholischer humor sehen sie von wegen
spaßbremse ja am fall wucherpfennig ist
gar nichts lustig hat der alte fiat
fahrer in rom nicht selber gewarnt dass
herbst franziskus markt immer wieder
homosexuelle gläubige nicht zu
diskriminieren
wer bin ich um über sie zu richten an
dessen äußerungen fühlte sich stets auch
priester wucherpfennig bestätigt und
darauf hatte ich mich verlassen ja das
war aber auch dumm also sich auf den
papst verlassen
der mann redet in gleichnissen wie in
der bibel wenn da steht einer hat mit
drei fischen 5000 leute gespeist dann
weiß ich doch der hat in wirklichkeit
den praktikanten zu noch sehr geschickt
gleich was und wo henry ist ja kein
einzelfall
ein katholisches gymnasium in borken im
münsterland hat gerade einen total
beliebten lehrern mich übernommen weil
er schwul ist und seinen freund heiraten
will
im jahr 2018 alle kollegen und die
schüler haben dagegen protestiert
ja ja das finde ich auch total gut dass
den da demonstrieren aber der lehrer
bleibt der schwung bringen
im übrigen mit schul seien an sich haben
will der katholischen kirche ja gar kein
problem
dieses hobby theologin bringt es auf den
punkt es ist mehr als eine neigung ich
habe ja gesagt [ __ ] seien völlig in
ordnung homosexuell seien völlig in
ordnung dass energie also als ich nicht
akzeptiere oder auch die katholische
kirche nicht akzeptiert ist wenn es
ausgelegt wird
man muss es nicht ausleben gibt auch
andere möglichkeiten ganze generationen
von geistlichen haben sich im stillen
kämmerlein einen von den psalmen gebetet
katholischer humor ist doch unfassbar
wenige wochen nach dem missbrauchs
enthüllungen blast york schon wieder als
moralische instanz auf vielleicht sollte
sich die kirche mal insgesamt aus dem
ganzen untenrum themen raushalten
bisschen vorsichtig mit dem ton er wirke
einfach noch mal im kopf nachrechnen wie
viele kirchenvertreter sitzen im zdf
fernsehgarten 4
aber die haben humor ich arbeite sogar
gerade selber an meinem eigenen kirchen
comedy-programm hier kleine kostprobe
bitte hallo köln seid ihr gut drauf sagt
der papst
was wollt ihr denn alle von mir ich tue
doch achtung vatikan kommt schneller als
gedacht sehen sie dennoch alle besorgt
warum gehen ameise nicht in die kirche
weil sie insekten sind was haben der
heilige stephanus und ein opel vectra
gemeinsam beide sind märtyrer
dort stehe uns allen bei johannes
stockmeier damit haben
[Applaus]
[Musik]